on l'apprend seulement aujourd'hui mais
depuis le début de la semaine 14
personnes dont 13 enfants sont
hospitalisés gravement intoxiquées dans
plusieurs départements du sud ouest
elles ont en commun d'avoir consommé des
steaks hachés surgelés acheter dans les
magasins leclerc
neuf de ces enfants sont dans un état
préoccupant
les lots à risque ont été retirées de la
vente le point avec christelle meyrals
ses parents viennent de vivre dix jours
éprouvants où leur enfant de neuf ans et
demi et hospitalisé ici à toulouse
depuis la semaine dernière à la suite
d'une grave intoxication alimentaire
sans doute lié à la consommation de
steaks a varié
l'enfant a subi trois dialyses et deux
transfusions dans le week end
les parents sont désormais soulagés elle
est nouvelle pour notre fit sont plutôt
rassurantes
maintenant
donc quand on est arrivé
on savait pas on savait pas qu'elle
allait être l'évolution commence à
l'espace et enfin s'il allait s'en tirer
à sans séquelle pas on a vraiment vécu
ça
jour le jour est et dans l'angoissé
évidemment dans le sud ouest
huit autres enfants de 2 à 9 ans sont
hospitalisés leur pronostic vital n'est
pas engagé il aurait aussi consommer de
la viande toxiques
tous sont victimes d'amal rare le
syndrome hémolytique et urémique une
forme grave de complications de gastro
entérite due à une bactérie
l'escherichia coli elle se développe
surtout chez les enfants et les
personnes âgées
les principaux symptômes sont la fièvre
les douleurs au niveau du ventre mais
des douleurs qui sont douloureuses
longue et c'est mal calmé par les
traitements habituels des diarrhées
aussi avec du son mais qui persistent
dans le temps c'est pas quelque chose
qui va durer 24 48 heures ça persiste
dans le temps malgré les 30 le
traitement habituel donné par exemple au
cours d'une consultation par le par le
médecin et sa durée l'enfoncer puiser se
fatiguent
au total 14 personnes auraient été
intoxiqués par des steaks hachés
surgelés de marque chantegril il aurait
été mise en vente dans des magasins
leclerc dans quinze départements du sud
ouest
leclerc procède au rappel des lots
variés portant les numéros l 231 et l
234 date limite 22 août 2006 le lot l2
sont six portes lui la date limite du 25
juillet 2006 tous ces lots ont été
préparés par la société sobibor
des analyses sont en cours pour
déterminer les causes de l'intoxication
alors